what's up reject nation we had no idea
that there was some ps5 event going on
somehow we were like the only two people
who had no clue about what was happening
today he's not supposed to come in
tomorrow so we're gonna try to get as
much as we can done now I've only been
catching up on gaming within the last
year so with that in mind I called up my
brother Jack away I was like all right
we have to move on to shooting some
other stuff which ones should we check
out well I got John here for the next
hour or so I was like you gotta check
out horizon forbidden West and I was
like I don't think John's put it and
I've definitely haven't played the first
one
he's like doesn't matter you'll
appreciate it anyway you should check it
out I'm like all right I'm following
your advice but I wanted to be upfront
with you guys about that this is how it
was the first time I saw last of us part
two trailers now last was one of my
favorite games of all time so maybe this
will be a situation like that who knows
you know I got a whole list of games
I've been catching up on because I'm
gonna have to add horizon zero dawn to
the list let's check this out
it is the 31st century
years ago
you play as the crabs I would have no
fish this is mo I know a little bit
machines
Wow
technology ruining the environment
looks like infrared photography
who
[Music]
whoo-hoo
[Music]
Wow look at that movement so real
that Lance Reddick Shirley oh my god I
think he made me in the first house in
the first one
Oh
new new
I don't know let's go Adama I got nipple
- Wow
oh my goodness well you know I credit us
I'm being like one of those reaction
channels that can usually provide like a
good amount of commentary afterwards but
that's why I gave you guys the heads
[Laughter]
normally around these events or time of
the year I always try to find like my
gamer friends who are familiar with the
prior installments so that way you know
like I ask them questions or let them do
a lot of the commentary here but it
looks like I'm adding this to the list
because I have been catching up I
actually have been and I have been
playing a lot of games and it looks like
now horizon zero dawn is added to that
list do you know anything about horizon
zero dawn I don't know any of the actual
details of what the world or the plot is
about I picked up on things that simply
seemed like it was ancient civilization
yet technological advancements with some
metaphors that are liking in it -
technology and mankind destroying nature
and environment that's what I was
gathering here I could be way off
because I haven't played the first game
but that is well at least was especially
what the first part of it was alluding
to to me and please comment it's going
to use some advice here on what the hell
is going on yeah I mean the little I do
know about this game you're in the
futures the 31st century and it's in
this world where you know there are
pockets of humans who are persisting and
subsisting but they're scattered around
they live amongst these machines they
refer to as machines are yeah these big
giant kind of animal-like creatures that
I think are you know fully automated I'm
not sure if there's an organic component
to them or not in the game or but yeah
you're sort of I think an outcast from
the society or whatever village you were
from and you know you're out exploring
and trying to bring order and I assume
some kind of ecology to this world okay
so yeah I mean obviously it's the future
but as that H a civilization I meant
more like the aesthetic it's like yes I
imagine that this is yelling after some
kind of major crash and now we're
rebuilding and yeah adapting and it's
the new dawn of civilization whoa crap I
mean it looks freaking gorgeous I was
like wrapped up in the emotion of just
the tone and the mood
weirdly for me when I say catch up what
ends up happening a lot of times as I
watch a trailer for a sequel installment
then I gotta play the first one now or I
got to put the prior ones yeah yeah be
thankful this is in resident evil
villager a decade's worth of vegan
service apt to catch up I mean the main
character looks freaking awesome
mmm my warrior woman yeah I love those
and and all the designs of it it's
sci-fi but feels completely fantastical
at the same time like it looks like it
has this fusion of all these things this
is just a big guessing game for me right
now I don't know if Lance Riggs in the
first one but you seeing him here it got
me excited
he's from Jonah Hex guys I think your
mentor I believe but don't quote me on
that well you know it's an effective
trailer oh not feeling all this feeling
of elation and gun nipple Chili's going
on and yet I'm like you know because
this looks like a very open world and
this is only the second one I got
certain vibes of other games that fit
into this mold of like nature oriented
future fantasy I thought of like Crysis
or destiny and in certain regards just
because yeah you have these beautiful
almost utopian settings of foliage and
then these horribly dystopian run-down
human societies and I gotta say there is
a real special neck I think these games
have when they do these like abandoned
underwater cities or they take monuments
and they adapt them for these worlds and
stuff because like looks like the Golden
Gate Bridge or whatever at the end yeah
it looks like Avatar meets Aquaman sure
oh yeah yeah yeah no there was any
swimming in the first
you know if you want to take things up a
notch add water oh crap that was awesome
and this main character is girl aluminum
oh you know we're going off the best of
recollections yeah yeah I mean she kinda
reminds me of like tauriel from The
Hobbit franchise how do we do feel free
to ponies noobs in the comments I always
get nervous I know plenty of reactors
will still do that most realistic
reaction yeah nothing what is going on
set yourself up for why are you doing
this if you have to watch play the first
game because maybe this will convert us
and we will become fans and we'll play
the game that's half of me with making
it's already in the last couple years
uncharted last of us said we're just a
couple of examples to say the least so
this could be that video yeah don't get
an Arkham games too so yeah alright guys
well subscribe click that bell let's
shout out a poor lonely paper Tyler hey
Tyler hey how can I not shout you out on
a ps5 trailer wouldn't be able to catch
up on so many games on a ps4 if you
didn't give me one for my birthday that
way I could rub it in John's face every
time I'm catching up being like yo you
played this game I don't have ps4 well
you sucked John you're a [ __ ] that's
what I do every single day it's for the
last two years it's how we agreed thanks
to you and dude I'm just letting you
know my birthday's coming up again his
it's tomorrow birthday last year's it's
not birthday tomorrow but my birthday's
coming up and I've got a few months so
I'm just gonna say it's either go give
you some time to save up mm-hmm
and get me a pre-order of that PS 5 I'm
just saying you know does this mean I'll
finally get to touch the ps4 when you
get the PS 5 no that's going in I don't
know your bedroom
ability if you could play ps4 games on
PS let's not chance it John of course
and for all I know we could be playing
the PS 5 playing some ps4 games on there
but then one day PS 5 might just be like
we don't want that to be allowed anymore
I gotta be prepared for work space right
tell you what by the time we get to PS 7
then maybe you can borrow my PS it's ok
it's ok add the last of us for like a
year John ps3 you gotta play that first
and then we can reconsider the ps4
discussion especially with how great
lots of us twos going down see Tyler
that's why you're getting me a PS 5
because I eventually catch up